Did your scale weight go up overnight
even though you're in a fat loss phase?
I cannot tell you how many times I've been so
disheartened when I stand on the scale
and see the number go up
despite being in a calorie deficit
and doing everything right.
I'm about to tell you why
your daily weight fluctuations tell
you nothing about your fat loss progress.
First thing to know, though,
is that daily weight fluctuations are completely normal.
It happens to all of us
and it's just a part of the process.
And there are so many things that can cause these
fluctuations,
so let's get into it.
No.1 is water retention from eating more carbs.
For every 1 gram of carbohydrates our body's store,
it also retains around 3 to 4 grams of water.
If you eat more carbohydrates,
you will likely weigh heavier the next day
because your body is retaining more water.
No. 2 is meal timing.
You eat dinner or dessert later than you normally do,
you will likely wake up heavier the next morning
because you haven't given your body
enough time to fully digest that food.
This basically just comes down to digestion.
It has nothing to do with your progress
or how adherent you've been to the plan.
No.3 is inflammation from training.
Have you ever noticed that after a really hard or high
intense training session,
you look a little bit watery afterwards?
This is just inflammation in the
Body from being in a state of stress
will likely show up on the scale the next day oh no
you did not gain weight because you did more exercise
next one is hydration
if your body is dehydrated
or if you can assumed more sodium than usual
your body will likely retain more water
and at this is just water retention
and will likely show up on the scale as well
and the last one is hormones
this one's particularly important for females
surround your menstrual cycle
it is very normal to
the scale jump up pretty dramatically
for example
I have one client on my program who scale weight jumps
up over 2 kilos around the time of her cycle
you will notice around your time of the month
there are a lot more
fluctuations that happen on the scale
and it's not a reflection of your fat loss
grass to my biggest recommendation is to not look at
the changes that happen from day to day on the scale
instead you wanna look at
your average weight from the week
I use Excel spreadsheets to do this for me
and my clients
and once you have the averages for the week
you're actually looking at
the changes that happen from week to week
and month to month
see this all the time with my clients
but a lot of the time
when you're looking at the changes from month to month
you'll notice that each week
the Amount of weight that you lose is very different
and since there might be a week where you lose
no weight on the scale
and then the next week you lose a full kilo.
So don't get caught up in
the changes that happen from day to day.
Look for the weekly averages
and then measure that from month to month.
Really hope you found this video helpful
because it's something that took me
so long to get my head around.
If you enjoy content like this,
make sure to hit that follow button
because I share similar videos to this all the time.
Hope you all have an amazing day
and I will see you in my next video. Bye.